- What's up believe nation,
my one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
I started the believe life
series to help us learn
a little bit more about ourselves,
grow personally and ideally,
bring some of what we learn
about ourselves to our
business to have more success.
So today we're going to
learn how to gain confidence.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well,
and if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going
live, you have a chance
to win one of two daily prizes.
(upbeat music)
- I don't know if you'd
agree with me on this,
but in many ways, one of the key factors
to legendary success isn't
your natural ability.
It's not whether you
have the right product.
It's not whether you're
in the right field.
It's not whether you've
had a blessed background.
It's not whether you have the right IQ.
I want you to really think
about and deconstruct
and play with, maybe later
tonight in your journal,
I want you to deconstruct
this idea of confidence.
And it seems like a very simple word,
but just think about it in your own life.
When you have confidence,
or we could even call it
fire, when you have that fire within you,
that confidence, that interior bravery,
you almost have this power
to do whatever it takes
to get your brave vision done.
You see, in this world it's not about,
in many ways your
strategy in your business,
or your ability in your life.
It's about this thing called confidence.
And we've all had these times in our lives
when we are full of confidence,
and what other people see
as a problem, we do see as an opportunity.
Other people see it as a
stumbling block or a wall,
and we see it as a stepping
stone or this solution.
And so confidence is something
that you really want to wire in.
Confidence is something
you really want to develop.
Confidence is a practice.
Confidence is a muscle,
and like any muscle,
the more you focus on it and practice it
and train it, the stronger your
confidence is going to grow.
And I just have to say it again.
When you are at a place in your life
when there is an ongoing,
steady stream of confidence
moving through your mindset,
moving through your heartset,
you do the heroic in your
business and you achieve
the remarkable in your life.
- Confidence secret number one
is eliminate negative people
from your life.
Negativity is more contagious than crabs.
When you surround yourself
or have negative little
cancerous people in your life,
they directly impact your
confidence in a negative way.
Negative nasty people.
Nasty.
Not like good nasty, bad nasty.
As in get the freak away from me,
I want nothing to do with you.
Now, here's the issue,
when I say, hey, you just
get rid of negative people.
It's like poof, they're gone, right?
Wrong.
Because a lot of times, we
have these negative people,
or these energy vampires all around us.
They might be at work,
they might be at school,
they might actually be related to us.
Does this mean that you
may need to find a new job?
Yeah.
Maybe a new relationship?
Mm, quite possibly.
Is it going to suck
for a little while now?
Yes.
In the long run is it
going to pay off big time
in terms of your confidence?
Yes.
- Psychologists often call it
the confidence competence loop
and as you become more
competent in something,
you learn how to do it, you're
more confident in doing it.
As you learn how to ride a bike
and you've rode the bike
more and more and more,
you became more skilled at it,
you developed more
confidence in your ability
to ride the bike.
Any area of your life,
you're going to go into
for the first time, be
okay with being uncertain.
Be okay with being uncomfortable.
Be okay with not knowing
how it's going to turn out.
'Cause it's your first time.
But stumble into it anyway.
Because if you stumble
into it, you develop skill.
You develop comfort with
it, and then something,
one day, you wake up and say,
I'm pretty confident doing this.
Nothing changed in who you are.
What changed is your level of competency,
knowledge, skill, and ability.
That's what competence is, knowledge,
skill, ability and talent,
And so when we finally
realize, oh, wow, I just need
to learn a little bit more here,
I'll be more confident.
I just need to apply this
a little bit more here,
I'll be more confident.
As you develop skills and
abilities in your life
in your unique areas, you
become more confident.
- Study the alchemy.
Now here's what I mean by that.
What happens to most people in life,
especially the victims,
is they reach a part
of their life, a difficult time,
and they call it failure.
I mean even just labeling
a setback as a failure
triggers something into your mindset
to release cortisol, the fear hormone,
which blocks your best performance.
And so you want to see
yourself and you want to study
the alchemy, which is where
other people are seeing
a failure or setback or
even a little problem
you want to look for the gold.
You want to train your
brain so you have a dominant
belief that just becomes
automatic because you've practiced
it so much, where when someone
says there's a problem,
or there's a wall, or there's a failure,
you literally see the alchemy
to turn the lead into gold.
Maybe you're going through a divorce,
maybe you're going through an illness,
a lot of people who watch this podcast
are going through difficulties
or outright tragedies,
but you want to practice
seeing the setback
or the dark time as fuel
to leverage your growth.
And so on this first point
about study the alchemy,
no matter what you're
going through in your life,
whether it's a large
difficulty or a small setback,
you want to ask yourself, how can I use
what I'm going through
as fuel for my growth?
You want to ask yourself, what
is the gorgeous opportunity
hidden inside this so-called problem?
I mean and if you look
at the mass of humanity,
they really train their
brains to focus on problems.
Right, they hit a wall, and they just,
because of their belief system,
they don't know it, because
most people are really
not that aware of their belief systems,
so they blame it on the world.
They blame it on the supplier.
They blame it on the teammate.
They blame it on their husband or wife.
They blame it on their childhood.
Versus understanding our daily performance
reflects our deepest beliefs.
And so if you are experiencing
some kind of setback,
whether it's large or tiny,
you want to train your
brain to see the treasure
within the lead.
- But if you want to
convey honest confidence
that inspires people, make
sure you can back it up.
As much confidence as Ali had,
and as much as he showed he
was just as good in the ring,
but that wasn't everything that Ali had.
He was also a dominant
force in every interaction.
Watch here how he completely
ignores the reporter
telling him that he isn't pretty
and delivers one of his most iconic lines.
- I'm the king of the world.
- Hold it, hold it, hold it.
- I'm pretty.
- Hold it, you're not that pretty.
- I'm a bad man.
I shook up the world.
- This kind of interaction
might look insignificant,
but it happens all the time
and it is very important.
It is a clash of frames.
We've talked about this
before in different videos
on tearing, if you want to check that out,
but right here, Ali's frame
says that he should be
doing the talking.
The reporter's frame says
that Ali should listen
because he's asking questions.
Those two frames collide
and Ali, as always,
comes out on top.
The winner of any frame collision
is going to be the person
who believes their frame
more, but watch here to see
the subtleties of how
that is communicated,
and I want you to pay
attention to three things.
First, how Ali doesn't
look at the reporter,
but the reporter looks at him.
Second, how Ali doesn't respond
to what the reporter says,
but the reporter responds to him.
And third, how the reporter
tries to physically pull Ali
towards him, but Ali doesn't budge.
- I'm the king of the world.
- Hold it, hold it, hold it.
- I'm pretty.
- Hold it, you're not that pretty.
- I'm a bad man.
I shook up the world.
- That took about eight
seconds, which is as long
as it takes for there to be
a winner in a frame game.
These short little frame
collisions happen all the time
throughout your day, in
tons of different ways.
And what's remarkable is
that from what I can tell,
Muhammad Ali always stayed
firmly rooted in his own frame.
When we see that kind of conviction,
we can't help but be drawn to it.
Here's just another little
example that you might relate to.
When two people go to give
different styles of handshakes,
watch how Ali maintains his frame.
(clapping)
(environment drowns out voice)
Ali isn't trying to be a jerk.
In fact, he was very playful
throughout this interview.
But he has grown accustomed
to setting the tone
of the interaction.
Pay attention in your own
life in subtle little ways.
Who do you make adjustments for,
and who do you stick to your guns with?
That's a pretty clear
indication of who the leader is
in any sort of relationship.
Now, there is no problem
with taking a follower role
sometimes, but in certain
situations, like sales pitches,
interviews, even dates, you
are usually going to benefit
from being the leader.
So those frame games
become very important.
Ali was so confident,
had such a strong frame,
that he seemingly had
no fear of being honest.
That might not seem like a big deal,
but most people are extremely afraid
of what others would think of them,
if they were totally real.
- I'm a social psychologist.
I study prejudice, and I teach
at a competitive business school.
So it was inevitable that I would become
interested in power dynamics.
I became especially interested
in non-verbal expressions
of power and dominance.
And what are non-verbal
expressions of power and dominance?
Well, this is what they are.
So in the animal kingdom,
they are about expanding,
so you make yourself big, you stretch out,
you take up space, you're
basically opening up.
It's about opening up.
And this is true across
the animal kingdom.
It's not just limited to primates.
And humans do the same thing.
So they do this both when they have power,
sort of chronically, and also
when they're feeling powerful
in the moment.
And this one is especially interesting,
because it really shows
us how universal and old
these expressions of power are.
This expression, which is known as pride,
Jessica Tracy has studied.
She shows that people
who are born with sight
and people who are born congenitally blind
do this when they win at
a physical competition.
So when they cross the
finish line and they've won,
it doesn't matter if they've
never seen anyone do it,
they do this.
So the arms up in the V,
the chin is slightly lifted.
What do we do when we feel powerless?
We do exactly the opposite.
We close up.
We wrap ourselves up.
We make ourselves small.
We don't want to bump into
the person next to us.
So again, both animals and
humans do the same thing.
And this is what happens
when you put together
high and low power.
So what we tend to do
when it comes to power
is that we complement
the others' nonverbals.
So if someone is being
really powerful with us,
We tend to make ourselves smaller.
We don't mirror them, we
do the opposite of them.
So we know that our
nonverbals govern how other
people think and feel about us.
There's a lot of evidence,
but our question really was
do our nonverbals govern how we think
and feel about ourselves?
There's some evidence that they do.
For example, when we, we
smile when we feel happy,
but also when we're
forced to smile by holding
a pen in our teeth like this.
It makes us feel happy.
So it goes both ways.
When it comes to power,
it also goes both ways.
So when you feel powerful,
you're more likely to do this,
but it's also possible
that when you pretend
to be powerful you are more likely
to actually feel powerful.
We decided to bring people into the lab
and run a little experiment,
and these people adopted for two minutes
either high power poses or low power poses
and I'm just going to show
you five of the poses,
although they took on only two.
So here's one.
Couple more.
This one has been dubbed the
Wonder Woman by the media.
Here are a couple more.
So you can be standing
or you can be sitting
and here are the low power poses.
So you're folding up, you're
making yourself small.
This one is very low power,
when you're touching
your neck, you're really
kind of protecting yourself.
So this is what happens.
They come in, they spit into a vial.
We, for two minutes say,
you need to do this or this.
They don't look at pictures of the poses,
we don't want to prime them
with a concept of power.
We want them to be feeling power, right,
so two minutes they do this.
We then ask them how powerful do you feel
on a series of items,
and then we give them
an opportunity to gamble,
and then we take another saliva sample.
That's it, that's the whole experiment.
So this is what we find.
Risk tolerance, which is the gambling,
what we find is that when
you're in the high power
pose condition, 86% of you will gamble.
When you're in the low power
pose position, only 60%,
and that's a pretty whopping
significant difference.
Here's what we find on testosterone.
From their baseline when they come in,
high power people experience
about a 20% increase
and low power people experience
about a 10% decrease.
So again, two minutes and
you get these changes.
Here's what you get on cortisol.
High power people experience
about a 25% decrease,
and low people experience
about a 15% increase.
So two minutes lead to
these hormonal changes
that configure your brain to basically be
either assertive,
confident, and comfortable,
or really stress reactive.
And feeling sort of shut down,
and we've all had that feeling, right?
So it seems that our nonverbals do govern
how we think and feel about ourselves.
So it's not just others,
but it's also ourselves.
Also, our bodies change our minds.
But the next question, of
course, is can power posing
for a few minutes really change your life
in meaningful ways?
So this is in the lab,
it's this little task,
it's just a couple of minutes,
where can you actually
apply this, which we
cared about, of course.
And so we think, it's
really, what matters,
where you want to use this
is evaluative situations,
like social threat situations.
Where are you being evaluated,
either by your friends,
like for teenagers, at
the lunchroom table.
It could be for some people speaking
at a school board meeting.
It might be giving a pitch
or giving a talk like this
or doing a job interview.
We decided that the one that
most people could relate to,
because most people had been
through was the job interview.
So we published these findings
and the media are all
over it, and they say,
okay, so this is what
you do when you go in
for the job interview, right?
(laughing)
So we were, of course,
horrified, and said, oh my god,
no, no, no, no, that's
not what we meant at all,
for numerous reasons, no,
no, no, don't do that.
Again, this is not about
you talking to other people,
it's you talking to yourself.
What do you do before you
go into a job interview?
You do this.
Right, you're sitting down,
you're looking at your iPhone,
or your Android, not
trying to leave anyone out.
You are looking at your
notes, you're hunching up,
making yourself small, when
really what you should be doing
maybe, is this, like the bathroom, right?
Do that, find two minutes.
So that's what we want to test, okay?
So we bring people into a lab,
and they do either high power
or low power poses again,
they go through a very
stressful job interview.
It's five minutes long,
they are being recorded,
they're being judged also,
and the judges are trained to
give no nonverbal feedback.
So they look like this.
Imagine this is the
person interviewing you.
So for five minutes, nothing.
And this is worse than being heckled.
People hate this.
It's what Mary Ann La France calls
standing in social quicksand.
So this really spikes your cortisol.
So this is the job interview
we put them through,
'cause we really wanted
to see what happened.
We then have these coders
look at these tapes,
four of them.
They're blind to the
hypothesis, they're blind
to the conditions, they have
no idea who's been posing
in what pose.
And they end up looking
at these sets of tapes
and they say, oh, we want
to hire these people,
all the high power posers.
We don't want to hire these people.
We also evaluate these people
much more positively overall.
But what's driving it?
It's not about the content of the speech,
it's about the presence that
they're bringing to the speech.
We also, because we rate
them on all these variables
related to competence,
like how well structured
is the speech, how good is
it, what other qualifications,
no effect on those things.
This is what's affected.
These kinds of things.
People are bringing their true selves.
They're bringing themselves.
They're bringing their
ideas, but as themselves,
with no residue over them.
So this is what's driving the effect
or mediating the effect.
So when I tell people
about this, that our bodies
change our minds and our
minds can change our behavior
and our behavior can change our outcomes,
they say to me, I don't,
it feels fake, right?
So I said, fake it 'til you make it,
like I don't, it's not me,
like I don't want to get there
and then still feel like a fraud.
I don't want to feel like an impostor.
I don't want to get there, only to feel
like I'm not supposed to be here.
And that really resonated
with me because I want to
tell you a little story
about being an impostor
and feeling like I'm
not supposed to be here.
When I was 19, I was in a
really bad car accident.
I was thrown out of a
car, rolled several times,
I was thrown from the car,
and I woke up in a head
injury rehab ward, and I had
been withdrawn from college.
And I learned that my IQ had dropped
by two standard deviations.
Which was very traumatic, I knew my IQ
because I had identified with being smart,
and I had been called gifted as a child.
So taken out of college,
I keep trying to go back,
they say you're not
going to finish college.
Like, just there are other
things for you to do,
but that's not going to work out for you.
So I really struggled with
this, and I have to say,
having your identity taken
from you, your core identity,
and for me it was being smart,
having that taken from you,
there's nothing that leaves
you feeling more powerless than that.
So I felt entirely powerless,
I worked and worked and worked
and I got lucky and worked
and got lucky and worked.
Eventually I graduated from college.
Took me four years longer than my peers.
And I convinced someone, my angel advisor,
Susan Fisk, to take me on, and
so I ended up at Princeton,
and I was like, I am
not supposed to be here.
I am an impostor.
And the night before my first year talk,
and the first year talk at
Princeton is a 20 minute talk
to 20 people, that's it.
I was so afraid of being
found out the next day
that I called her and said, I'm quitting.
She was like, you are not quitting.
Because I took a gamble
on you and you're staying.
You're going to stay and this
is what you're going to do.
You are going to fake it.
You're going to take, you're
going to do every talk
that you ever get asked to do.
You're just going to do
it and do it and do it,
even if you're terrified,
and just paralyzed and having
an out of body experience,
until you have this moment where you say,
oh my gosh, I'm doing
it, I have become this.
I am actually doing this.
So that's what I did.
Five years in grad school.
Few years, I'm at Northwestern,
I moved to Harvard,
I'm at Harvard, I'm not really
thinking about it anymore
but for a long time I had been thinking,
not supposed to be here,
I'm not supposed to be here.
So the end of my first year at Harvard,
a student who had not talked in class
the entire semester, who I had said,
look, you got to participate
or else you're going to fail,
came into my office, I really
didn't know her at all,
and she said, she came
in, totally defeated,
and she said, I'm not supposed to be here,
and that was the moment for me,
because two things happened.
One was that I realized oh my gosh,
I don't feel like that anymore.
You know, I don't feel
that anymore, but she does,
and I get that feeling and the second was,
she is supposed to be here.
Like she can fake it, she can become it.
So I was like, yes, you are.
You are supposed to be
here, and tomorrow you're
going to fake it, you're going
to make yourself powerful,
and you know.
(clapping)
And you're going to go into the classroom
and you are going to give
the best comment ever.
And she gave the best comment ever
and people turned around
and they were like,
oh my god, I didn't even
notice her sitting there.
She comes back to me months later,
and I realize that she
had not just faked it
till she made it, she'd actually faked it
till she became it.
So she had changed.
And so I want to say to you
don't fake it till you make it.
Fake it till you become it.
It's not, do it enough
until you actually become it
and internalize.
The last thing I want to
leave you with is this.
Tiny tweaks can lead to big changes.
So this is two minutes.
Two minutes, two minutes, two minutes.
Before you go into the next
stressful evaluative situation,
for two minutes, try
doing this in the elevator
in a bathroom stall, at your
desk behind closed doors.
That's what you want to do.
Get, configure your brain to cope the best
in that situation.
Get your testosterone up,
get your cortisol down.
Don't leave that situation feeling like,
oh, I didn't show them who I am.
Leave that situation
feeling like, oh, I really
feel like I got to say who
I am and show who I am.
So I want to ask you first,
both to try power posing
and also I want to ask
you to share this science,
'cause this is simple.
I don't have ego involved in this.
Give it away, like share it with people,
because the people who can use it the most
are the ones with no
resources and no technology.
And no status and no power.
Give it to them, because
they can do it in private.
They need their bodies,
privacy, and two minutes.
And they can significantly
change the outcomes
of their life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I love to know what did you think,
what did you learn from this video
that you're going to apply immediately,
somehow to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to hear from you
and if you leave a
comment within the first
few hours of this video going live,
you might win one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kevin Lee.
Kevin, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and stopping by the studio
and taking a picture
and getting it signed,
and sharing it on Facebook.
I really, really appreciate
the support, man,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- And our weaker selves
think that success in life
is being happy, happy, happy.
Always being in the sunshine.
Always being successful.
And society has sold us a bill of goods
that if we're not successful
and we're not on our games
and if we're not waking up happy
and if we're not full of joy
and if we're not feeling
all this confidence
there is something that is wrong.
And with deep love and respect,
this could be one of the
most important things
I share with you in this podcast.
That is just your ego screaming.
And that's why I say
flow with the seasons.
A life beautifully lived
is a series of seasons.
A legendary producer is not always
at the top of the mountain.
And so stop resisting, I encourage you,
stop resisting the natural
flow of epic performance.
Stop resisting the
natural seasons of life.
You see, and so what happens
is that when you stop
struggling and you learn,
again, it's a muscle,
but you just learn to relax with life.
And you simply understand part of living
a legendary business
life and part of living
a rare air personal life
means you're going to have
seasons of so-called success in society,
maybe it's making a lot of
money, being really productive,
being at the top of your
game, receiving the accolades
of peers, feeling you
are nailing your goals
and your ambitions and your KPIs,
your key performance indicators,
and you're going to have
seasons where you're confused.
Seasons where you feel heartbroken.
Seasons where you feel depleted.
Seasons where you are struggling.
And the more you learn to
relax into every season,
the more you will generate
this internal power
which I call confidence.
- Secret number two, complement others.
How does it feel getting a compliment?
Exactly.
It feels incredible.
It also feels incredible giving them.
Here's the interesting
thing about compliments.
When somebody gives you a compliment,
you automatically like them more, right?
You're like, I thought he was a,
but he said I had nice shoes,
he's not so bad.
Follow along.
The person getting the
compliment feels incredible.
You feel great for making
them feel incredible
and they actually like you more.
The other up side to giving compliments
is that it helps you
develop your people skills,
leading to confidence and
increased social prowess.
- Human develops in its psyche.
We develop a real sense of competence
or confidence coming
from a sense of integrity
for ourselves, you know?
Integrity is I know who I am
and I am being that consistently.
I know what I want and I am
chasing that consistently.
Integrity being aligned with
who you are, your values,
your beliefs, and your
dreams, having integrity,
that gives us confidence in self, right,
that our self can stand
on its own and be itself
and do what it desires, that
gives us a sense of confidence,
so how have you been
doing in that department?
Have you been really
demonstrating who you are
to the world?
Have you allowed yourself to
do that, 'cause if you do that
over a period of time, this
self and I would argue,
the soul, senses a coherence, you know,
there's a cohesive sense
of identity that comes
from being consistent to
the best of who we are.
Confidence comes from that.
And that, too, is will.
It is decision.
It is a desire to want to
be a person of integrity
and confidence, and that's
where it stems from.